hello
and welcome everyone to the active
inference live stream
i believe we are live it is active
stream 9.0
and it is november 18th 2020
i am daniel friedman and i will be doing
a solo acting stream today
so welcome to team com everyone
we are an experiment in online team
communication
learning and practice related to active
inference
you can find us on twitter at
inferenceactive
at active at activeinference.gmail.com
our public key base team
at our youtube channel or um through any
other mechanism
this is a recorded and an archived live
stream so please provide us with
feedback so that we can improve on our
work
all backgrounds and perspectives are
welcome here and for video etiquette on
live streams
make sure to mute if there's noise in
the background raise your hand so that
we can hear from everyone on the stack
and use respectful speech behavior so
just a quick announcement before we
jump into the paper discussion you can
find on our twitter information about
the rest of our discussions for 2020 we
have six more
uh group act imp streams in 2020
on november 24th and on december 1st
we're going to
be in active 9 discussing the projective
consciousness model and phenomenal
selfhood
and that will be the paper that this
active stream 9.0
is context 4.
in active 10 on december 8th and 15th
we'll talk about the paper a variational
approach to scripts
while in act 11 on sophisticated
affective inference
we'll talk about more modeling and math
again and that will be on december
22nd and 29th so that will close out
and then we look forward to a whole new
panel of events
and projects collaborators for
so find out more on our twitter that way
let's talk about what we're going to do
in acting stream
9.0 which is right now so the goal of
active 9.0
is going to be to set the context for
9.1
and 9.2 which are going to be the group
discussions that we have on these papers
and the paper that we're going to be
discussing for 9.1 and 9.2
is called the projective consciousness
model and phenomenal selfhood
by willa ford at all 2018
and there's a link that people can see
the video
that we're about to jump into right now
is an introduction to the context of
some of the ideas presented by the
authors it's not
a review or a final word it will
contextualize some of the ideas
math and vocabulary that might be
interesting or
important to know for reading will
afford at all
2018 and the punch line that they're
going to work their way towards
is that we might be able to combine
fields such as
geometry cybernetics and
neurophenomenology
using the framework of active inference
and the free energy principle
to potentially understand or explain
consciousness
so that's going to be up to you up to us
how we feel about these kinds of claims
that they're going to get to in the
paper
but that's where we're headed and
the sections of 9.0 will be as follows
first we'll go through the keywords and
hopefully provide some background on the
different keywords whether it's your
first time hearing one of these words or
whether
you're in one of these fields and then
we'll talk about the aims and claims the
paper
go through their abstract and the
roadmap the sections then we'll talk a
little bit about consciousness
from the author's perspective just what
do the authors say
is important about consciousness and
what do they think are invariant aspects
of it
well then walk briefly through the
figures just try to understand what
are these figures even doing how are we
going to get a first pass on
understanding what these figures are all
about
and then in 9.1 and in 9.2
we're going to stay with this exact same
paper so save and submit your questions
and
feel free to get in touch with us if
you'd like to participate
whether that's in 9.1.2 or in a future
endeavor let's talk about the keywords
the first keyword is actually not on the
paper keywords but
is what we're about here is active
inference and the free energy principle
that's what we'll try to tie so much of
this back to and here were the keywords
that were listed
cybernetics projective geometry
consciousness neurophenomenology
first person perspective and
perspectival imagination
so cool terms maybe it's your first time
thinking about math and geometry in the
context of consciousness maybe it's not
but hopefully as i go through these
following keywords i hope that this is
interesting and exciting whatever
level of familiarity you have with these
concepts
so first keyword is cybernetics and it's
also written there in russian as
kubernetes
and there's many resources to read on
for the history of cybernetics some of
which we're going to talk about here
because in a lot of other
active streams and other locations you
can probably hear about the mathematics
underlying cybernetics
and about how it's related to control
theory both things that we've talked
about
on this stream but let's talk a little
bit about just
more historically or from a cultural
perspective what is cybernetics what is
it trying to do
cybernetics is a school of thought
tradition of action however you want to
think about it
that's related to the action policy
selection and control
of goal-oriented systems now
there's various orders of cybernetics
which we can sort of walk through here
and um i'll go through a couple of
different resources on
cybernetics and hopefully you'll see
soon why i put a history citation
on the bottom left and a little bit of
russian on the top it's not just because
we have great russian colleagues in team
com
here are the orders of cybernetics
there's probably different ways to state
them or think about them
first order cybernetics might be thought
of as self-regulation without
detailed observations so this could be
like a negative
feedback system that is able to maintain
a semblance of homeostasis
in virtue of being an isolated or a
closed process like
there's something that gets triggered
when it's too hot and then as soon as
it's triggered
it's too hot it instantly kicks in a
cooling program
second order cybernetics is um
self-regulation that can be influenced
by observers within a domain of control
so that could be for example
continuously varied
thermometer that's able to enact
different kinds of control policies
as a function of continuous inputs from
the thermometer
third order cybernetics is
self-regulation that is influenced by
observation
with a relational basis or an ecological
grounding
so the system in this third or
cybernetic loop
is able to acknowledge its surroundings
and learn develop and evolve
and fourth order cybernetics is when
self-regulation
involves the enactment of multiple
different realities or adjacencies
affordances counterfactuals a lot of
ways you can think about that
in terms of a functioning creative
observer
so these are deeply contextualized and
integrated systems
that are doing higher orders of
cybernetics and i'm not a stickler about
which order is which number
i also on purpose drew the parallel with
the
um one two and three loop thinking which
is related to
um some decision-making theory from
innovation and the entrepreneurship
space but i just thought it's
interesting
here's a figure from the um book
chapter cybernetics in the 20th century
on the bottom left there
and it shows a map of concepts and how
they're related to cybernetics
so on the left are sort of two inputs to
cybernetics which are control theory and
the idea of control and then
communication theory and the idea of
communication and information
and so those are two branches that we've
talked a lot about on this stream and we
will continue to talking
be talking a lot about because control
of action
and communication message passing these
kinds of things
inference is the thread that runs
through them all these kinds of things
are critical
for control theory for cybernetics for
the kinds of systems we want to
get into working with on the right side
we see cybernetics branching back out
into the machine area with the
engineering sciences and the planning of
for example complicated factory
operations but as well as into the
animal and the social levels
so the animal cybernetics is about for
example the self-regulation of behavior
and the social cybernetics could be
about um the way that our
governance is run and there's a really
interesting book read plenty
that's kind of like historical fiction
about cybernetics
speaking of history this is such an
interesting plot and it was in the
cybernetics book figure 16.
it is the usage of the term cybernetics
and control by years in the text of
publications
publications indexed by google scholar
so caveats
maybe people are speaking about it with
different words or it's being used
a different language not english or
there's some other way of saying it
but look at how similar these things are
in terms of their trends
where both of them ramp up gradually
leading to in early 2000s
a lot of discussion of cybernetics and
of control
potentially looking backwards a couple
years so think about these peaks in the
early 2000s
as potentially reflecting something at
the close of the 1900s
and then how they both start to drop off
and this is consistent with something
that a lot of us
have experienced which is that
cybernetics is a term that a lot of at
least
english speakers may not be too familiar
with but we can look at the journals
that fristen and others have published
in
we find a lot of connections to
cybernetics
what is going on there so to get a
little sense of what is going on
two other resources to look into would
be this big history understanding of
complexity information in cybernetics
and then this book which i'll read a
quote from right now which is called
from newspeak to cyberspeak
a history of soviet cybernetics by slava
garevich
and the author writes in this book from
the history of soviet cybernetics
followed a curious arc
in the 1950s it was labeled a
reactionary pseudoscience and a weapon
of imperialist ideology
with the arrival of khrushchev's
political thaw however it was seen as an
innocent victim of political oppression
and it evolved from a movement for
radical reform of the stalinist system
of science
pretty interesting in the early 1960s it
was hailed as a science in service
it was hailed as a science in service of
communism
but by the end of the decade it had
turned into a shallow fashionable trend
using extensive new archival materials
garovich argues that these fluctuating
attitudes reflected profound changes in
scientific language and research
methodology across disciplines
in power relationships within the
scientific community
and in the political role of scientists
and engineers in soviet society
his detailed analysis of scientific
discourse shows how the new speak of the
late stalinist period and the cyberspeak
that challenged it eventually blended
into cyber
newspeak so maybe there was a book
summary of this um
work but pretty interesting how that
plays out and so
definitely we'd love to learn more about
this whether we have
russian speaking colleagues who could
fill us in or anyone else
next key word projective geometry
what is projective geometry about well
of course you could go down the rabbit
hole with this topic but let's just try
to keep it constrained to what the
authors are going to use it for in terms
of the paper
they write the concept of a 4d
four-dimensional
projective transformation is central to
the model
as it yields an account of the link
between perception imagination and
multi-point of view
action planning great okay so what is
happening here and how can we understand
this
and its relationship to projective
geometry i'm going to introduce just two
ideas here with this visualization
the first by looking at the bottom is
the distinction between the euclidean
and the non-euclidean types of spaces
and then the second idea with a purple
arrow is this idea of a map
or potentially you could call it a
mapping because it's actually a process
and it's actually a certain type of
process it's a projection
so we're talking about projective
geometry we're talking about
geometry which means this the shape of
things and the spaces that they're
existing in so as opposed to topology
which is how things are connected
connected with nodes and edges geometry
is about things and their shapes and
their spaces
we're going to talk about projections
amongst
different geometries specifically
potentially this one between
euclidean and non-euclidean geometries
and here's a quote that they write
authors do they write
this perspectival phenomenal space so
the space in which
they're going to say that experience
occurs within phenomenology occurs
within
a space allows us to locate ourselves
and navigate in an ambient space
that is nevertheless essentially
euclidean however
in a euclidean space there are no
privilege points
no points at infinity no horizon and a
no
and an arbitrary origin they say there's
no non-arbitrary origin
same thing this version this very
strongly suggests that a non-euclidean
frame must be operating
in the phenomenal space with the help of
sensory motor calibrations
to preserve the sense of the invariance
of objects across the multiple
perspectives adopted
and relate the situated organism to the
ambient euclidean space
so what is it that allows me to continue
thinking about this as a pen
even as it comes very close to my face
and looks very
weird so what is that generative model
that allows me to
act like everything's normal as objects
maintain their invariances
as the eye travels through the space and
so we can contrast this euclidean space
that
they're supposing that we exist in
they're saying we exist in a space that
doesn't have privileged points of access
no points at infinity etc etc um and
they're saying the space that
an organism for example moves through is
euclidean while the space
that their consciousness is being
projected into
experientially is non-euclidean what
about it is non-euclidean well let's
just take the opposite of what's in red
and put it in blue
so there are privileged points from the
point of view of the observer that is
the privilege
point of view quite literally there can
be points at infinity
there can be points that sort of just
like they're so far away they're
infinitely far away and not just from an
affordance point of view but from a
perception point of view
there can be a horizon in fact we see it
every day
and there can also be a non-arbitrary
origin which is a little bit of a
restatement the idea that there could be
a privilege point but basically it's
privileged it's a non-arbitrary origin
these are pretty similar concepts
now non-euclidean it's like saying
non-linear
and the joke about this is things that
are not elephants that's the
non-elephant class
you'll know when you see it so that's
about how helpful it is to say it's
non-euclidean or it's non-linear model
okay we get it it's not linear model
it's not euclidean geometry but there's
many choices
and the reason why even though it sounds
like wait you're barely ruling anything
out
we're actually ruling out very specific
parts of the geometry of the euclidean
space
so in euclidean space parallel lines
don't intersect but that's not
necessarily
um the case for certain types of
geometry or
a triangle with three edges and three
angles is 180 degrees from the sum of
the angles but on a sphere it's not that
way
so that is what is happening with these
geometric projections
is we're going to be projecting from
sort of the um
grid they want to think about now you
might want to ask bucky fuller
if we're actually in a euclidean space
or if it just seems that way because of
public education
but for the purposes of this paper we're
in a euclidean space
as action and that's the space we want
to be making our perception
uh simulate so to speak and to act like
everything is normal
and to decrease our uncertainty about
euclideanly mapped
space while also relating it to
through a projection something that does
have a privilege point of access
and something that is as they put it
informed by sensory motor calibration
and relates to our action affordances so
that's how you can have a euclidean
concept of for example um a gap in the
ground that you can't jump over
so it's a very complex estimation of
what you can do and how big the gap is
and where you are
how much run up you would need etc all
of that is going to come together
by doing what they're going to talk
about here now
consciousness um it's great to talk
about consciousness and i'm going to go
into a little bit of detail soon about
some of my own thoughts on the issue but
when talking about consciousness
it's important to be really clear even
though it's something that we're not
always sure about it's always important
to at least use language very carefully
and use our scholarship
and our intercultural respectfulness
very importantly because
as i'll hopefully come back to a few
points soon it's just a critical issue
and we can't think of it
um just flippantly the authors write
when talking about consciousness because
i want to just go with what they think
about consciousness for here
they write we might divide contemporary
neuroscientific
and psychological theories of
consciousness into three main types
the biofunctional the cognitive
neurofunctional
and the information theoretic as should
be clear
the projective consciousness model the
pcm incorporates the emphasis on
self-awareness common to many approaches
to consciousness
as well as an emphasis on the biological
functions of consciousness
so they're defining the space a certain
way i'm going to define it a different
way
soon but they're defining it that way
then we're going to insert the pcm here
and then they write at the end the pcm
thus
subsumes and unifies the main insights
in all of these approaches
to consciousness above all what we add
to pre-existing theory is a geometry
the thesis that projective
transformations and projective frames
necessarily subtend the appearance and
workings of consciousness
so whatever we're going to learn in this
actin stream or whatever we think the
pcm is doing and we want to evaluate it
not by
um what it doesn't do but what it does
do and what it claims to do what it sets
out to do
that's where they're trying to step in
their understanding of literature and
consciousness is that they broke
consciousness down into these three
kinds which citations exist there
you can read the paper and then they're
going to step into that gap
and then they're going to make the claim
that they're subsuming and unifying the
main insights from these approaches
where does that leave these approaches
from a theory perspective
question for another day but that is
where the authors understand their work
to be fitting in so if you don't know
what the pcm is or it's kind of trippy
to think about what it means to do
mathematics and geometry of
consciousness
that's perfect here is the blank that
they're going to fill in with their work
what do i think about consciousness
though and i want to be clear about what
my
stance is or at least just give the tip
of the iceberg on my stance because this
is a first person active stream
and there's some relevant research i'll
discuss in a few minutes
and also i've just for a long time been
interested in the science of
consciousness but also this second layer
of how it's communicated especially from
scientists
so there's a lot of places to go here
and a lot of places to start
i'm just going to walk through a few
general thoughts and raise a few
questions
really more questions than answers and
then i'll discuss a paper
from the last couple of years with a
colleague eric sonic
all right so there are many ways to
think about studying
consciousness and one path that you
could go down
um this is sort of you know across
cultures through the time
one path you can go down is thought
experimentation so this could look like
meditation it could look like a specific
thought experiment um or some other sort
of insight approach or a gudangan
approach and whether it's culturally
called one thing or another
is not as much my concern here the
thought experiment approach doesn't
involve
making interventions for example in the
outside world just thinking about
consciousness you know
hearing ted talks and stuff like that so
the issue
is that um whatever is actually
happening if that's what we're pursuing
um we could just be led to the wrong
conclusion and then if there is some
element of
free will or interventionary role of
consciousness then
we could intervene to um end up
believing
that we couldn't intervene or any of
these accommodations so i just never
quite understand the relationship
between
what one directly feels convinced about
with respect to a thought experiment or
a thought or an idea
and how that might relate to how it
actually is for people who aren't that
person
and one aspect of this is that it's
really impossible
to know which aspects of thought
experiments can be transferred to other
situations
so for example one of the most famous
papers in this area
most cited papers is a 1974 paper by a
philosopher named nagel
and that raises the question what is it
like to be a bat i don't think he
invented that question
um but he's the one who got famous for
it and in that paper
it's written an organism has conscious
mental states if
and only if there is something that it
is like to be that organism
something it is like for the organism
now you might think
what are philosophers doing because it
sounds like a
sort of a weird question and i
understand that many
uh careers and a lot of good thinking
has come out of this question so i want
to optimistically see it as a catalyst
in a seed
it's always good to have simple
questions to return to it's good that
it's such a simple
question and it opens to so many
perspectives it initiates students into
our knowledge traditions
there's so many advantages to having
these kinds of classic works
but to be that um uh to be blunt i guess
i find the phrasing of this question of
consciousness to be quite unhelpful
because it is so informal it's so
hypothetical it's untestable it's
ambiguous but it's specific it brings a
bat into question
and then you can imagine oh it's a dog
what is it like to be a dog now these
are all good things to imagine
but again they don't really bring us
closer to addressing real frameworks for
consciousness
and the reality is there's been now a
vast wasteland of literature that's just
not
comparable to other work in the same
exact space across different species
that essentially amounts to speculation
and appealing to what it might be like
to be a certain type of animal
thinking well if i was really a bat and
i grew up as a bat would i ever like
thought
uh what it was like to be a human how
would i so it ties up to all these
second level
questions that aren't super relevant and
um
we've always wondered through time every
culture everyone has wondered what other
systems experience
whether that's in a person or an animal
or a fictional character or a physical
object
so the speculation and the think pieces
they don't really add something
substantial to the literature
which is what the scientific literature
is about for me so the bigger issue
though
with thought experiments of any kind is
that we can always imagine things that
are just
not making sense within a framework or
any framework or just don't relate to
the world that we live in
we all know that we can be wrong about
an idea but believe that we're right
and so um to kind of rephrase that in an
active inference framework we can say
that
these are situations where the precision
parameter is very high
there's a belief a metacognitive belief
that the precision is high that some
question has been resolved
um this represents that um for example
someone's model of consciousness whether
it came from a knowledge tradition or
their own thinking
they believe that they're they're on to
it they got it figured out it's resolved
for them
but um that doesn't mean that your s
your estimate is related to s
hat the actual state in the world and
i'm not passing judgment on
being overconfident or um being wrong
because sometimes it can be very
important and powerful to have these
kinds of beliefs but
that's not what being correct is about
and so if you actually don't care about
being correct being right going towards
the truth
and you really don't care about that
then um i'd love to hear
where you're coming from um the rest of
the scientific literature
although with many shades and many
differences
is moving towards what actually would be
general as generalizable through truth
so let's go back to consider
experimental approaches which is
something that comes up a ton
in the philosophy and the science of
consciousness literature
now it would be awesome to do
experiments on consciousness and in some
way don't we all
we could study humans as they behave and
sleep and daydream
take um psychedelics or they wake up for
anesthesia and they develop and there's
so many things that could be exciting
to learn about also if we can do
experiments on consciousness we could do
experiments on animals
now we could do experiments that are
interventive like
manipulating the brain of an animal or
the body or the situation of an animal
these experiments might be seen as
inhumane or just to massively violate
ethical standards for humans
and so there's a bit of irony in doing
these potentially invasive
non-consensual experiments with captive
or wild animals
when we're studying potentially their
capacity to not consent
to our discussions with them it's an
interesting
question i won't go down the ethics
route here but a non-ethical question
that's related to experimentation is
that we just don't know which systems to
study
or what observables to measure for
experiments and so we're studying
something that isn't really
measurable or observable but we'll come
back to this idea of observability
in a few minutes when we're talking
about neurophenomenology
and the reality is no matter what you do
measure even if you come up with this
one special measurement that hasn't been
done before
all experiments are interpreted within a
cultural and a scientific milieu
in terms of what measurements
conclusions interpretations are
ethical correct accepted valid discussed
all these things
and even going another layer back about
experiments even
assuming that we can measure what we
want to know and measure and everything
experiments especially if they're
disconnected from
grounding in theory it's difficult to
know what is really being uniquely
tested
or demonstrated or falsified by
different kinds of experiments or what
we can learn from different kinds of
measurements
and there's a lot of ambiguity a lot of
levels the ambiguity can enter into but
just to give a few examples an
experimental result could be consistent
with many different frameworks or
potentially all frameworks
or a set of frameworks for consciousness
so when we really want to be identifying
what frameworks we're
wanting to work with it doesn't narrow
the space as much
to do experiments which we'll return to
soon and that's kind of related like the
neural correlates of consciousness
debate
which is do you put somebody in a neuro
imager and then have them do a no report
paradigm where they don't say yep i
heard the sound
so you play sounds of different uh you
know notes but what if it just
subconsciously
influenced their brain there still could
be a neural signature of that how would
you know they experienced it
well that's called a report paradigm you
ask them did you experience it
but in some sense you're just asking
them if they remember or if they hit the
button so
it gets messy but that really gets into
some of the weeds about what you're
measuring
and another example or area where we see
limitations on
experiments related to consciousness is
in animal behavior
so animal behavior seems naturally like
it'd be adjacent to human consciousness
studies
and we see a wide variety of things
being used here like pulley tests can
two of the same animal
pull a pulley so they get a reward
looking in a mirror
can one recognize themselves and take an
action pattern to clean themselves in
the mirror
and the first thing to note is that
whatever kind of setup you're dealing
with a visual illusion
a cooperation task a recognition task
memory planning
they're always going to be based upon
the affordances of that animal
and again it might be ambiguous as to
whether they're using some q that you
actually expect
um or if it doesn't see it's not going
to be able to be in the mirror test
so at the very least these tests for
consciousness which we'll get back to
don't help us really study the ground
rock
of this frameworks for consciousness
question because all you could say is
okay this bird can do the pulley test
but we don't even know what that means
and then of course if we find out that
potentially experience isn't related as
much as we thought to behavior or
if one has a model that it's not related
to behavior then
you could say yeah it's a robot that
just acts like it's a crow all right i
think i'm still streaming but it looks
like my camera froze i'm not just
re-plugging in um
yeah actually i'll just
see if i don't know what it's about but
that happened uh
last time as well but c'est la vie
i'll just close the camera for now
um actually let me just see if i can
remove the source
and then add the camera back in i'm
going to find out live
whether it is obs being weird or whether
it is
the actual usb connection
and turns out it was obs
we now know and we're right back
in it so
um to the point about potentially robots
or zombies as dennett might put it doing
uh complex behavioral tasks uh you
wouldn't know
whether the experience was being had
even if the behavioral experiment you
had lined up for this animal was
enormously complex and uh
robots might be able to do things that
we might not expect them to be able to
do
already such as learning language or
being culturally embedded and so yet
another point here is that
before you get too excited about any
single experiment
that might prove or disprove a model of
consciousness
consider it just another grain of sand
on a sand heap
and any single grain of sand that you're
adding to the seat back could be the one
that sets the whole cascade in motion
so by all means i encourage
experimentation but that being said
let's not fool ourselves in pretending
that
many of the data points we already have
are out there in the world already
and that just one more experiment is
unlikely to provide
any type of knockout evidence for or
against a model of consciousness
and so to kind of recap there there's
the thought
experiment branch the philosophy
meditation insight route and there's the
experimentation interpretation route
and uh those are connected of course
experiments are ideas too
but that being said they both have pros
and cons and people will often argue one
or the other as if they have um the
answers from one branch or the other i
hope i've
demonstrated that that isn't true and
one
reason i think that it's important to
have this viewpoint is that
we're living in a world just as a primo
fascia observation where there's some
people
humans who say that they think all
things are consciousness
or that all things are consciousness in
their own special way or that nothing is
conscious
including humans and of course there's
many flavors to each of these viewpoints
that could be held
or at least communicated and there's
many things about beliefs about
consciousness that might not be verbal
or expressible in a certain language
so the point is we're in a total state
where the evidence in the world has
resulted in people believing different
things through time
different things even within the same
family and so
let's be humble the table has mostly
been set for us in terms of observations
about
ourselves and about our world though it
doesn't mean we can't reimagine
much of our own experience or the world
but um it would really have to be quite
the thought experiment or quite the
experiment
uh in the real world if it can resolve
these long-standing and philosophically
grounded differences in worldview
between schools of thought and between
people
and even if it did this even if the
experiment
were so good that it just convinced
everyone it wouldn't even mean it was
right
it would just mean that it was
convincing as a meme and so
if we're really trying to find out
what's right rather than how can we
shape our own reality and other people's
which isn't always the worst task
if we want to be right then as far as i
know it's not going to be the experiment
or the thought experiment
route alone and one last point on this
slide because there's a lot to say here
is that
there's academics who believe different
things and you can see these slides and
citations and see that
they cite different work that says one
thing about the global workspace
or another thing about information
theory there's also different views on
consciousness
from different world traditions from
artists
from practitioners from non-scientists
from non-philosophers
from all kinds of people children adults
everyone this is just to say that we
should be very cautious
about any kind of hegemonic especially
scientific
effort to define consciousness whether
it comes from academia or
from some other source there's just way
too much on the table here
for people to be making sweeping claims
about what is or is not
conscious uh and there's a lot
that is downstream of that it's really a
personal and a cultural
thing what somebody believes about
consciousness
what they want to say or what they want
to commit to
and also while some people might find
these topics exciting i think they're
exciting if you're listening you
probably find them to some extent
exciting as well but many people
are not interested in considering it and
don't
perhaps want to be told this is how
their consciousness or experience is
and other people are simply okay not
knowing whether they're curious about it
or not
and so i'm always skeptical about
science says type thinking which can be
often how scientific papers are written
even if it's written in an author's
say type thinking it's about how it's
communicated we've all seen the misuse
of science says
policy related to everything and
consciousness would be the next level on
that wouldn't it be
so fill in the blanks think about what
kind of power is held by the people
who can say what or who is consciousness
or evaluate conscious states such as
suffering or pleasure so there's just a
lot to it
and then um the last point really here
is that people can change their beliefs
during their own lifetime and go deeper
and shallower into different
ideas and that probably doesn't change
the underlying nature of consciousness
so it will never be enough how we think
at one moment
or for a group of people to believe
something i've gone down these
discussions and roads many times with
people
um alone and in conversation and people
will tell me well you know we're working
with our best possible understanding of
consciousness given the research at this
time
and it's just simply not true there's so
much
to know and respect in terms of the
research and also the non-scientific
literature
on consciousness that there is just a
lot more to the discussion than well
let's just tell the kids something
simple to it
now to go beyond that and thanks for
bearing with me
it was just i wanted to say a few of
those things because a lot of times
consciousness
papers are approached from
non-scientists
with excitement so i want to provide a
little bit more of a nuanced scientists
take here
on how we can really respectfully study
consciousness because this isn't just
like fristen at all figuring it out in a
paper
but i love the paper and it's
interesting so how do we hold this yes
and
perspective through nuance hearing
multiple people's perspective having
participation
so what i'm going to talk about here is
this paper
that i worked on with my colleague eric
sovik who's a professor
in norway and the paper is called the
ant colony test
as a the ant colony as a test for
scientific theories of consciousness
so this is how i came to be thinking
about a lot of these topics
now professor soviet's background was in
neurobehavior and in genetics of the
honeybee
mind was in similar areas but related to
ants
eric is also a very pragmatic and a
philosophical
thinker his phd advisor who is andy
barron
at macquarie university in australia is
a honeybee biologist
and professor barron has also written
philosophy papers
that are related to entomology as well
as to experience and consciousness
uh on my side my phd advisor professor
deborah gordon
at stanford is an ant behavioral
ecologist
who also wrote a lot of philosophy works
broadly construed and so both eric and i
had really positive
mentors and role models for how we could
combine entomology with philosophy
so that's where we were coming from with
this paper was
how can we combine our direct
ethological
behavioral ecological experience with
the social insects
with what we knew about neurogenetics
and molecular biology
and then tie that through respectful
engagement with some of the philosophy
of consciousness
literature here's what we didn't do in
the paper
what we didn't do is make a claim or a
bet
on whether ant colonies are conscious or
not
whether ant workers are conscious or not
if people have
feelings on that let's hear about them
on the active stream let's find an ant
stream let's do something fun
let's hear about it but that's actually
not what we did in this paper
we do a few things in this paper the
first thing is that we proposed
this terminology of a forward and a
reverse test for consciousness which i'm
going to return to in a second with this
image
the second thing we did was to review
the literature on consciousness from
scientific literature
and make classification schemes for
different kinds of theories of
consciousness
so you can see why i was interested in
the breakdown of this
paper's understanding about the fields
of different
scientific studies of consciousness and
then the third part of the paper
we used empirical findings from
entomology so
observations of morphology or of
behavior
of individuals or of colonies from
entomology and we asked whether
different frameworks for consciousness
that we found during the literature
review
might come to the conclusion that ant
colonies and
or workers had consciousness or
awareness
and we as authors remained neutral on
the issue to the extent we could as far
as just
presenting hypothetical evaluations of
colony of consciousness
from the point of view of these
different frameworks which is something
that's so intrinsic to consciousness so
it's kind of fun
and it turns out that frameworks just
simply wildly diverge
in their claims about ant colony
consciousness and
it's really not a surprise that it
turned out to be that way
because the same frameworks diverge in
their claims
pretty plainly and people diverge in
their opinions
and so if the frameworks are going to
disagree about humans being conscious or
electrons
then they're going to disagree about
ants and
it was just interesting to experience
this though and ask how we could have a
reconsideration of what we're really
doing here with the consciousness
studies area because there's thousands
of speculative papers
about consciousness and animals but are
we moving the needle and if we are
in what direction is that where we want
to be moving it
what did we do in the paper so we
introduced this idea of a forward and a
reverse
test for consciousness and we thought
about forward in reverse
just from the point of view of the
observer the experimenter
so that's very related to this
phenomenological invariant
idea that the pcm model is going to
return to in a little bit
and this idea that everything in
consciousness should be relational let's
take this perspectival and this
relational approach
very seriously so what is a forward and
reverse test
a forward test is when you trust your
test and it describes the mode of usage
of
tool where you're measuring systems and
drawing conclusions
so for example in the figure it says i
trust my test how heavy are these boxes
and we have this gray test
it says it it's an unknown whether the
box is conscious or not
we put it on there it says yep one and
then we go out in the world and we
investigate whether different boxes
are um different weights or a
consciousness or whatever and
that is for validated calibrated
instrumentation and it's important for
the normal
in a paradigm uh vocabulary the normal
science which is advancing
science and a reverse test is a
different phase a reverse test is when
you don't
trust your test yet and this is like
calibration and calibration
is when you take things that you do know
about like we know that the meter is
this much
relative to this and we know that the
wavelength of this is going to help us
calibrate this tool
but really just when you use a
scientific instrument it has to be
calibrated
and if we want to have a science of
consciousness we have to have a
calibrated instrument
and so the reverse test is when you
don't trust the test and you don't know
what the machine is going to read out
but you put on the one pound block
and you say i'm going to fine tune this
machine so that it comes out with
one when i put the one on there and then
we'll know that this scale or this
spectrophotometer
works and it's kind of this back and
forth this two-stroke
engine that we've seen so much about and
we've been talking about um the back and
forth
between action and inference of course
we've been talking about that from the
framework of computationalism
from the bayesian perspective the
bayesian structuralist perspective
in activism and ecological psychology
and just
cognition in general agency how do we do
this forward and backwards of
more tool-like based upon affordances
and more inference based upon
observations
okay so it's kind of a two-stroke engine
for studying consciousness from a field
perspective so this is like what should
the field of consciousness researchers
be
studying now wouldn't it be great
if we had a forward test for
consciousness if we had
a scale that we could go yep we hooked
up this person's brain or
this wi-fi router or this beetle and yet
it's a two out of four it's a 2.9 out of
you know whatever it is
yeah sounds great i understand why
people want to mathematize and why they
want to measure consciousness
but if you meet somebody who has a good
test
for consciousness then you know get the
tesla tech
get the perpetual motion machine get
everything you can from that person
because we don't see it within the
current space
we're in we want to have this test
prefrontal cortex language whatever it
happens to be no caveats just a test
of course it doesn't exist and so that's
kind of what this issue is about
and so when we don't have a forward test
for consciousness even though people
might think they locally have one i hope
i've sort of dispelled that with a
previous slide
if we don't have a forward test to
operate in the action mode
do we have a reverse test to help us
work in the inference
mode so that is um where
professor cervic and i wanted to think
about different kinds of forward tests
for consciousness and then
how could the ant colony be a reverse
test for consciousness so here's the
framework that we
loosely organized into for our
literature framework
um in terms of forward tests for
consciousness so this is like what other
people might call frameworks for
consciousness
we said look all these models what they
have in common is that there's some
measurements some
tool-like intervention or um
intervention into the process or
measurement
that could be done that would help us
have a forward test so like
is this system conscious does it have x
does it have language does it have a
prefrontal cortex
okay now the reverse test for
consciousness would be like we know
humans are conscious
so any theory that says that is fine
with me or
we know humans are not conscious so i
rule out any theory that says that right
whichever one you think you believe fine
so we separated into a few different
categories the first one was
neurobiological so remember that they
had three categories biofunctional
cognitive neurofunctional and
information theoretic
what we did with our slightly different
breakdown of
the categories in the space not a final
word this is just what we had uh
found out about is we divided
neurobiological models
into the following categories which were
structural models that were based upon
macro
or micro uh structure so macro structure
would be like
the cerebral cortex is this size or it
has this brain region so gross anatomy
macro structure the micro structure is
like wow there are so many connections
on the dendrites or
this cell type has this shape so things
that you'd need a microscope to see
macro to micro so you need the
microscope for the micro histology or
oh the architecture of these neural
networks is a feedback
that means that it could be implementing
something so macro microstructure of the
brain
neurobiology or of the brain in the body
for that matter because it's not always
about the brain
functionalist models for um
consciousness would be like
there is a function that does egocentric
navigation
in crawfish and crows and humans so
these are
conscious entities so because there's a
functional
element of something that's being done
even if it's being done in
non-homologous brain regions
or two different ways by two different
species or in somebody who was born with
vision or who wasn't born with vision
it's the function that matters and then
another neurobiological
assessment that people often make in
terms of forward testing
is dynamical features of brain function
so they'll say
well because the brain is a complex
adaptive system with winnerless
competitions and leaky integration
and action policy selection and um lock
and voltair
um you know uh predator prey type
dynamics or
chaos and landslides catastrophes power
tail of noise
all of these dynamical features coming
from usually a complexity or a signal
processing perspective
so those are the kinds of appeals that
people make to the brain and the body
there's also the egocentric and
relational frameworks for thinking about
what counts as a model of consciousness
and in this category
there's a bunch that we could go into
but just to make it kind of clear what i
mean by egocentric and relational which
is actually the first invariant
principle of the pcm so
totally agree it's critical it's on the
idea of spatial awareness and perception
which is um whether it's the lived
experience or just the acting as if
of things being closer to you being more
accessible but everything
in consciousness is experienced in
relation to
something that's agreed upon even when
people don't even agree what that
relationship is or what that something
is so
that's kind of cool um then there are
cognitive and behavioral frameworks so
these are cognitive
being broadly understood as like things
that computers might be able to do or
computer networks or
extended cognition embedded enacted and
cultured all this stuff that we talk
about every week
let's take that broadly to cognitive so
here by cognitive i don't just mean
what people think of happening between
you know the student's eye
and them filling in the multiple choice
test that's not just cognition
we want to have a broad understanding of
cognition multi-scale
message passing bayesian nets etc and
the categories here
are um there's multiple but examples are
like
emotional or affective states kind of
foreshadowing um the sophisticated
affect of inference which will be active
11.
but emotional states like regret um or
optimism bias and cognitive biases more
general
so everything from visual illusions
to other types of illusions that are not
visual but can be related to the order
of things being presented
these are sort of cognitive effects that
potentially like a neural network
might fall victim to and so what we've
experienced
is that there's this run around and
people say well this bird has this brain
region so it's a macro structural claim
so it's conscious and then
somebody brings up a shortcoming of the
idea of macrostructuralism
like well does it really mean that it's
aware just because it has this brain
region what about sleeping people or
what about you know daniel dennett or
something like that
and they go well right it's actually the
brain region and the microstructure okay
so it's microstructural great well
then would anything with that
microstructure have that kind of a
characteristic
um like if you made a model and a
computer would it have awareness well no
it has to be evolved or it has to
have language or it has to be
implementing something ecologically
great so we want to chase that rabbit
down
because we're serious about answers here
and so we want to chase it down someone
says oh well when i said language i
didn't just mean a chatbot
i meant they they feel emotion you say
well but what if the chatbot says it
feels emotion too what are you gonna do
and then all of a sudden that whole
feeling emotion um communication of a
feeling emotion
all of a sudden they have a new
explanation so let's keep on
chasing down these rabbit holes and uh
one other category that is closest to
what is described in this paper
is the mathematical framework so we took
a step beyond the authors
in the um 2018 paper the projective
consciousness model
where they said there's the information
theory category of consciousness models
we actually separated a few of these
models of mathematical frameworks so we
have decision making and long-term
planning
um as well as information theo theoretic
geometrical
so there have been some maybe it was
published similar
or slightly after this paper but there
have been some geometric theory of
consciousness
info theory and then also a lot of times
the information theory approaches deal
with information geometry
so which one is it i agree that it's
enough to call it mathematical and just
say
includes topology information theory
thermodynamics geometry
just a lot of math stuff um another
area of mathematical frameworks for
consciousness could be like cybernetics
which is why it was one of the key words
for this paper
because a mathematical framework for
consciousness might involve
decision making or agency or ability to
plan
at a certain level of coherence and in
fact in the 2018
interview that was with carl fristin
myself
and our passed away colleague martin
forger in the last question of that
interview
i asked him whether he thought the ant
colony was conscious because i was
working on this paper with eric
and i was writing the interview with
carl and then i just thought wow we
could figure out what carl thinks about
ant colonies being conscious and if
you're interested in
either fristenology or in ant colony
consciousness then
definitely review carl's answer on that
but just to kind of close this slide off
um we're committed to long-term clarity
on these
issues about the study of the science of
consciousness so we really
welcome collaboration or improvement on
these
questions let's work with it let's make
an ontology for consciousness or
how are we going to get organized on
this issue because as i said there's
just too much on the table to let this
one slide
and we have to enter this space and do
it right
because otherwise just it goes off the
rails
okay let's get to neurophenomenology
which is one of the key words of the
paper oh yeah the paper
and on the bottom here i have a couple
just fun images
the left side is the book geb
by douglas hofstetter 1979 but reads as
crisply as ever and uh really
an insightful book and then on the other
side uh of
uh is the tree of knowledge this yellow
cover by uh varela and maturana
and that's a book about autopilesis and
a few other
topics that are really cool related to
complexity
and just very deeply related to the
ecological and activist
semantic biobehavioral a lot of great
stuff
also potentially the work of frijoff
capra
is one thing to look into here but then
some images because it's not all about
language
so here's some images by magritte and by
m c escher
that have to do with sort of what is
this self let's look at how the authors
define
neurophenomenology they define it as one
observation and description of the
phenomenological invariance at the
appropriate level of abstraction
so maybe the appropriate level of
abstraction for the experience of
drinking water is not
uh you know a throat cell maybe it's uh
not a whole
nation maybe it's a person the
classification too classification of the
behavioral cognitive and biofunctional
aspects of consciousness so
some drugs like you know you take
acetaminophen and it doesn't make you
feel that different there's other drugs
that are psychoactive or that have
long-term changes to your brain
whether you experience it in the short
term or not so how are we going to get a
behavioral
cognitive molecular genomic
understanding of
fat mechanism three identification of
the neuroanatomical and
neurophysiological correlates of
consciousness
so i see neuroanatomy as the structural
whether it's
function structural at the macro or the
micro neuroanatomy is what soviet and i
called structure then neurophysiological
is um referring to the dynamics and the
processes
molecular informational whatever they
may be that are in the brain so those
are the functionalist models to me
of the brain four development of
mathematical and computational models of
consciousness which i would consider to
be in the mathematical category
that a faithfully integrate all the
invariants described in one which we'll
get to
soon b provide unifying explanations
of intestinal hypotheses about the
bio-functional aspects of consciousness
described in two
all on board and c can be physically
implemented in the hardware identified
in three
as well as perhaps in non-biological
hardware so i
don't subscribe to computationalism i
don't believe in a hardware software
distinction except as a useful metaphor
in biology i think the book wet wear is
pretty interesting
on this topic and the reason why i
intervened right after the mathematical
and computational models is because i
think it's actually a different domain
i think there could be a mathematical
model that's extremely agnostic to the
biology
or our biological model could just be
like it is what it is
and it doesn't matter what the math or
what anyone thinks the math is
it is what it is because of evolution or
um because it
passed through some sort of historical
filter and any equation you put on it is
just like a linear regression
it just it doesn't matter so those to me
they can kind of fly together and that
would be great or not
it could be something totally off base
which is why i think again it's
important that even though we have
the citations and the ways that we can
sort citations into
keyword clusters let's not think that
we've mapped out the space of the
possible
in consciousness because there's people
in other cultures
who don't feel the same way as
scientists
first person perspective is i think the
last key word
and they write about that in the paper
they
say ideally this method of the pcm would
give us a theory of consciousness that
intelligently links the phenomenology of
a first-person conscious experience with
its realization in the brain or other
substrate
via mathematical and computational model
simultaneously accounting for its bio
functional properties
so the bio functional properties is kind
of where you got the
neuro part the mathematical
computational model
they're saying wouldn't it be good for
purposes of describing it predicting it
controlling it designing it
explaining variance reducing our
uncertainty why not
that's the mathematical computational
side and then
pull it all the way back phenomenology
so computational neural phenomenology
we're going to be doing mathematical
computational neurophenomenology in this
paper
and we're going to be using geometric
tools like projection mapping
to think about how cybernetics and
active inference
are related to classic work in
neurophenomenology
okay one more keyword perspectival
imagination
so they quote on this one they write
this perspectival space of the field of
consciousness foc
is organized around an elusive implicit
origin or zero point and
includes a horizon with vanishing points
at infinity that mark its limit so right
there there's the two of the violations
of euclidean geometry
point of privilege that's the point of
view and then the vanishing horizon
points out infinity
the foc embeds vectorized directions
that frame the orientation of attention
and action
along three axes vertical horizontal and
sagittal so like
you know this one this one and then that
one
these are given in perspective with
respect to these same points at infinity
so pretty interesting stuff they
continue and they write
since we are dealing with a 3d
perspectival space with an elusive
origin point of privilege point of view
and vanishing points at infinity
constituting a horizontal plane
a horizon plane that happens to be in
the horizontal axis
it doesn't have to be if you're on your
side it's not
the pcm postulates that the field of
consciousness has the structure of a 3d
projective space in the sense of
projective geometry
nice thanks for giving it as a keyword
too it helped me learn about it
the foc can thus partly be understood in
terms of 3g projective frame
let's look at a few just kind of cool
examples related to perspectival
imagination
so this is an example of a non-euclidean
geometry it's an escher
uh artwork and it's like these bats that
kind of fractal
off and sometimes this could be related
to hyperbolic geometry or other
geometries but the point is like each
bat might be
flying off and so that kind of maps onto
our experience of a bird or about flying
away from us and slowing down perhaps
but how is that going to get mapped onto
another space
that may or may not have three
dimensions spatially
again bucky fuller might claim there are
four spatial dimensions so let's not
assume there are three spatial
dimensions and that the fourth one is
time
that being said it makes sense to talk
about xyz
coordinates from a cartesian perspective
another
example about this perspectival
imagination is vanishing point so
everyone who's done a fun drawing course
or just looked down a city road or
looked out
of a car that was driving through fields
everything kind of vanishes
and so you can see the rows of a field
and you know that they're all in
parallel
but then you can see really deeply down
one other ones like kind of
move towards it and another way of
seeing it in a cityscape is like
you can conceptually know that the
street is straight but if you look at it
it looks like a triangle
that's disappearing from you with a
point at the top so
what is it that allows us to be like oh
yeah buildings have 90 degree angles
and they're going upright even though
all the actual angles are kind of wacky
so that's this perspectival imagination
and that's what makes an artist who can
make a lifelike drawing
especially like an architecture or
something look
lifelike because they capture these
extremely subtle
features about vanishing point and
perspective
and all these different things so one
drawing that i love on this is um
this one and it's like
for many people it's okay do a
self-portrait of what you see when
you um are on the couch and one approach
might be like
i just you know draw like okay i see
this you know here's this piece of art
here's my bookshelf
here's you know my bike then the next
layer back's like oh i'm going to
include my feet
in the drawing like the kind of you know
i'm on the beach here's my legs type
thing
like uh taking a picture from right in
front of you
with a phone something that we actually
have an affordance to do now but
other people may not have seen in such a
direct way
which is why they didn't take selfies
for example oh
hey here i am this drawing takes it back
another layer now this is actually where
are you really
seeing from not what is cancelled out
with a binocular vision
but what happens when you look with one
eye
really really far to the side well you
see this curving
and it's just like a little bit
beautifully accentuated
but of course we're seeing that as a
two-dimensional projection
so that's just so cool and uh
styles that play with our perception
like optical illusions or cubism
or abstract art they often incorporate
some
invariant features of perspectival
imagination but then violate
expectations on other ones so like um
half of the person's body is as if they
were lit from this side and half as
if is as if they were lit from a
different side that was a classic
technique of the cubists
and so very rich space
very open for honest collaboration
with artists and philosophers
and practitioners so we hope that this
is kind of an opening
for those who might have thought active
inference okay it's an engineering
framework
we're talking about optimization we're
talking about sociocultural things but
kind of from an abstract point of view
how are we going to take this into our
experience of consciousness and of
perspective
so i'm going to return to this slide
again and again which is that
it's a question what does free energy
principle and active inference
say about the relationship between the
world and agents
so that's this feedback between the
world and the agents and the nested
agents
and here we're adding on this level of
the agent is having conscious awareness
it's thinking i am a strange action
perception loop
or at least it's acting like it says it
or it's thinking that it's saying it
and just as we've talked about before
with this slide we want to be building
on
the fields of action of inference of
physics
of experience we want to be tying these
threads together
while also being aware that just being
convinced will never
be enough so that's why it's such a fun
area
why it's so great to do research in this
area and to learn about it and also to
welcome
collaboration and to welcome people
sharing their perspective
because i really believe that no matter
how many papers you've read about
consciousness
it does not make that opinion any more
valid
there's other topics where potentially
you couldn't say that as flippantly
but in the area of consciousness it
can't be a counting game
it's just not it's something that is so
essential to our experience and so
it's such a deep area a perfect area for
transdisciplinary synthesis
cool let's get to the paper because
it's also all about the specifics we
want to be really specific about what
the authors
say and do so that we can build off of
it with other specific work
so that we can actually um use their
perspectives
as catalysts for our own development not
push ideas out of our head and replace
it with you know the fristen
update but rather be catalyzed and
spurred to new
culturally informed creative states by
reading and by discussing so that's why
really especially for 9.1 and 0.2
for the last home stretch of 2020 and
for 2021 just
if you're listening to it we want to
know your experience and
we want to hear your questions in the
youtube chat
or have you on live however it has to be
this paper is called the projective
consciousness model
and phenomenal selfhood it was published
in december of 2018 in
the uh frontiers in psychology journal
in the division of theoretical
philosophical psychology
and the authors are willa ford bennequin
fristen and ridroff
so that's kind of giving you some
information on when this paper was
published
and on what areas the authors want to
place their work within
let's take some quotes from the paper
and look at the main aims and claims
of the work they write can we
describe this integrated multimodal and
centered spatial structure of conscious
experience in a rigorous way
great question i love the setup and they
write
and can we give a good account of why it
should be thus organized
here we answer both questions in the
affirmative great
questions i love the setup and it's
something we can evaluate
whether that's a hearty affirmative or a
half-hearted or uh
overly confident or underly confident or
okay it's affirmative but then what do
we do
these are all great questions to have
and i just love that the authors can be
really clear about this
great research and also a great
suggestion by a community member
to um read this paper overall
the pcm delivers an account of the
phenomenologically available
generic structure of consciousness and
shows how consciousness allows organisms
to integrate multimodal sensory
information
memory and emotion in order to control
behavior
enhance resilience optimize preference
satisfaction
and minimize predictive error in an
efficient manner
sounds chill if we could we should
great the way that i would rephrase it
without
any of the jargon of act imp is how can
we apply
active inference to the study of
consciousness in all of its
unified yet coherent mysterious
dynamic and profound facets so there for
the purposes of scientific writing
highlighting a lot of the vocabulary
keywords and research fields related to
control theory information signaling
geometry
math computation those are some heavy
hitting ideas
but let's also not lose sight that some
of the other heavy hitting ideas include
the mystery of consciousness
and why we're the one that we are and
whether cells have consciousness and
whether ant colonies do and whether
colonies do
but not nest mates and nest mates but
not colonies or
ecosystems but not colonies just let's
be
open-minded so let's answer questions in
the affirmative
and be open-minded let's have yes and
and let's accomplish yes and with
everyone's participation
the abstract begins with saying we
summarize our recently introduced
projective consciousness model
and relate it to outstanding conceptual
issues in the theory of consciousness
the pcm combines a projective
geometrical model of the perspectival
phenomenological structure of the field
of consciousness
with a variational free energy
minimization model of active inference
yielding an account of the cybernetic
function of consciousness vis the
modulation of the field's cognitive and
affective dynamics for the effective
control of embodied agents
long sentence double double points for
using uh affect and effect
long sentences but slow it down unpack
it
i think that we've gone through the
keywords well enough at least
a first pass to show you why it would be
great to connect across all these areas
abstract part two the geometrical and
active inference components are linked
via the concept of projective
transformation
which is crucial to understanding how
conscious organisms integrate
perception emotion memory reasoning
and perspectival imagination in order to
control
behavior enhance resilience and optimize
preference satisfaction
so sounds cool the pcm makes
substantiative empirical predictions
we'll see about that and fits well into
a neural computationalist framework of
course it does
it also helps us to account for aspects
of subjective character that are
sometimes ignored or conflated
pre-reflective self-consciousness the
first person point of view
the sense of mindness or ownership and
social self-consciousness
close the abstract with saying we argue
that the pcm
though still in development offers us
the most complete theory today
of what thomas metzinger has called
phenomenal selfhood
now i don't know medslingers work
incredibly well or what this topic
bridges out to
kind of an interesting way to end the
abstract but so it goes
um that's what we might be getting to
how are the authors going to
get from all of these keywords like
cybernetics and geometry
to getting to potentially the most
developed framework to date in their
opinion
of what is called phenomenal selfhood so
phenomenology experience selfhood
having a self well they start in section
one with the introduction
and go pretty directly to section two
methodology i think this is great
because it really gets
into the details quickly you could
philosophize for a thousand books
people have so what's the methodology
how can i identify
what you're actually doing in this paper
as a researcher
without hearing 30 pages about your
understanding of what descartes did or
didn't say
three they're going to talk about
phenomenological invariance and the
functional features of consciousness
which are also we're going to go into
them later and they talk about the
phenomenal
logical invariants what they are the
five of them we'll go through them
and then talk about how they're related
to projective geometry in the pcm
so basically they're going to start with
their invariance and if you have a qualm
with an invariant you want a sixth one
you want to collapse to four
great let's write another paper but
they're going to start with these
invariant features
and then they're going to introduce that
plus projective geometry
to say projective geometry is the bridge
we're gonna take
to get these five invariant features we
see figure one which has an account in
the pcm model of psychological phenomena
in figure two
which shows projective geometry in
relationship to the necker
cube which is like kind of a cool
illusion that i'm looking forward to
showing you
then they go to the five functional
features of consciousness which are also
what we're going to
address and they talk about the
projective consciousness model
which is remember the phenomenological
invariance plus projective geometry
equals part of the pcm now we're going
to talk about
the pcm and the functional features of
consciousness the functional
cybernetic functions that they talked
about earlier
and fuse that in the capacity of using
active inference and free energy
minimization to get some of these
functional dynamics
then they'll show figure 3 a simplified
2d print
projective consciousness model based
simulation of a pit challenge
and then figure four give a overall
sketch of the projective consciousness
model
in section four they talk about the hard
problem of consciousness
representationalism and phenomenal
selfhood the hard problem
and computational functionalism is um
variously phrased by
uh professor chalmers and others as
basically being about what the substrate
of consciousness is
why is it that when you hit your hand it
hurts but when you hit some brain
regions
uh it doesn't hurt and when you hit some
other brain regions you just
pass out you come back or you die or
something in between
how is that happening in the brain or is
it an antenna is it a generator
these are the questions then they
go from the computational functionalism
to talking about the pcm and
representationalism now all these terms
computation function and representation
are pretty loaded
we've gone into them on a couple of
other discussions but
be open-minded as to how they could
recombine
in the context of pcm and then they're
going to take those kind of
more quantitative terms computation
function
representation representation is a
little bit of a bridge and they're going
to bring that
into the projective consciousness models
phenomenological components
so that's going to be about subjective
character subjective character being
what it is-ness the what is it about to
be a bad
and also the phenomenal selfhood of the
philosopher that they concluded with
discussing in their abstract
and then they conclude so looks like a
great roadmap
let's in this introductory video in the
um time that i've left here
let's go through the functional features
and the invariances
of consciousness because we're not going
to have time to go through them in 9.1
or 9.2
with all of you contributing your
perspectives and it's good to get them
out here because these are kind of like
the big five for the functions and the
big five for the invariances
and if you have a qualm with the model
you should first ask is there a function
or is there an invariant that i think is
extraneous
um is there one that i think is missing
is there one that i think is just off
base
so if you have a question about one of
these five
things you think this doesn't go far
enough or this goes too far or
but some conscious systems don't have
that great that's the question you want
to ask
so there's five in each category if you
think there should be more or less or a
different one
that's one entry point now if you agree
with all them
and you say yep those are the perfect
five in each category then
you can evaluate given what projective
geometry is and what the pcm
is do they address the functional and
the
um uh experiential invariance
of consciousness so that's how we're
going to read this paper
and that's where i hope there's a lot of
footholds for people who
maybe have thought about consciousness
but this is a new way to hear about it
for them
it would be great to have their comments
what are the five
functional features of consciousness
according to the authors
and the way that they sort of justify
this is by saying
um we claim that the overall function of
consciousness
is to address a general cybernetic
problem or problem of control
control theory consciousness enables a
situated organism with multiple sensory
channels to navigate its environment and
satisfy its biological and derived needs
efficiently
this entails minimizing predictively
erroneous representations of the world
and maximizing preference satisfaction
a good model of consciousness must be
able to explain how this is accomplished
the pcm thus
emphasizes the following interrelated
functional features of consciousness
here's why i paused before putting it up
but after justifying it
because even things that do control
theory might not have consciousness
full stop that's the whole thing that i
was getting into with the ant colony
test
is okay so then if i have a robot
and it has something that allows it to
do multimodal integration across
sensors with a generative model with a
deep with a counter factual whatever it
is
does it have consciousness and then
that's where the person goes oh it needs
a brain
and so then they go down the rabbit hole
a different way so the function is
important but
again it's not the whole story
especially yet
here are what they characterize as the
five functional cybernetic features of
consciousness that we'd want to at least
explain
so maybe just passing these five is
necessary but it's not sufficient
but it's important one global
optimization and resilience
consciousness helps the organism
reliably find the globally optimal
solutions available to it given
competing preferences
knowledge base capacities and context
making the organism more resilient
this is a mechanism of global or
subjective here in the sense of
subjective bayesian optimization
which does not always obtain objective
optimality though it must approximate
the ladder reliably enough
uh or you die if you don't objectively
enough
figure out how to walk down a staircase
you're not going to walk down many
staircases
now a few things on this first many
people think consciousness is epi
phenomenal
so whatever is happening in our
awareness is not going back to guide
so this plays a little fast and loose
because it's saying well consciousness
helps the organism reliably find
it sounds like consciousness is coming
back and this is the whole cartesian
dualism
paradigm is like i know that carl
firsten and others have many more
nuanced works
including i think therefore i am related
works so i'm not
gonna go into it but it's like if
consciousness is something that reaches
back
into the physical how is that or if
consciousness is purely a descriptive
epi-phenomenal
epiphenomena above the phenomena of
mechanistically or
um materially defined components like
neurons message passing whatever it has
to be
ants no matter how emergent their
properties are
in the weak emergent sense do they ever
amount to strong emergence and actually
cause the system even the downward
causation
and causal entropy and the
renormalization group
that still is a very philosophically
agnostic with respect to whether it's
causal
so another thing to say here is that
global optimization
given the preferences knowledge base
capacities affordances and context
so so it's not global optimization so
it's local optimization
or it's global exploration of a
conditional space
conditional upon the things that we want
it to be conditional on
like how far you can reach but then
i don't know about you all but my
consciousness doesn't always help me get
to the globally optimal points
unless that global optimum is defined
as this not objectively best space of
like
well you just didn't go the right way
but it seemed optimal given what you
knew
it's like okay and then okay and it has
to be reliable enough
so i'm on board two global availability
the contents of consciousness must be
generally globally available in the
sense of poised
to be treated of by our effective
cognitive and perceptual systems as the
occasion requires
so for example you know here's idea one
idea two
memory four the color you know the
number all these things are just
apparently one layer away from accessing
the workspace this is drawing heavily on
the global workspace theory attention
schema
modeling of some other researchers i
would just point out global doesn't
make sense to me the brain isn't the
globe cognition isn't the globe
availability it's like yes but then
again you define available as like
i knew it yesterday but i don't know it
now so it's not available
um or what if it's part of my extended
cognitive process and it just takes me
five minutes to find it
so okay relevant but globally available
um and also our awareness is
hardly the tip of the iceberg um or
maybe it's
a whole iceberg and a half so i wouldn't
even know what it would mean to be
globally available
motivation of action and modulation of
attention
attention scheme of theory consciousness
is generally implicated in the
motivation of action
based upon affective dynamics and memory
this drives the modulation of attention
though consciousness is not to be
narrowly identified with attention so
that's kind of attention scheme of
theory breaking upwards
out of the just um like lstm like a
neural network that has an intentional
parameter we want to go into the
experiential dimension
not just the oh well it's a laser that
spends a lot of its time here
or um you know it's a camera that auto
focuses on this level
we want to go beyond that and say um
whether or not it is getting input like
a camera in some of its sensory organs
the experience is somehow generated but
i'd also point to this motivation of
action and modulation of attention
it's very very important these are
phrased as if consciousness
functionally functions of consciousness
right
motivates action and modulates attention
or it could be epiphenomenal
consciousness that is
and so it could be the experience of
motivation of action and the experience
of modulated attention
so in that framing we made consciousness
epiphenomenal and we basically said yeah
attention is something that happens with
all the neurons
and the firing patterns and whatnot and
you know the drugs everything that
happens
and then it gets to some synergetic
compromise where it's like looking at
this thing at this time
and then you're just experiencing it
it's not simply a cartesian theater
model
it's still a bottom up top-down um
situation but there's no simple outs
here
it's neither that consciousness is
reaching back and motivating action
neither is it that it's modulating
attention through what dials
you know show them to me oh well that's
what meditation is
yeah but then all of a sudden you're
getting into this area where i think a
lot of
stuff that's not related is pretty
important and then the fourth one oh
whoops i said
big five well let's just think of it as
the big five the big fifth function is
going to be the secret function
but the fourth function is simulation
enhancement maybe that gets us too
consciousness facilitates the use of
simulation in the broad sense of
imagination
not the narrow sense like simulation
theory um but maybe that's the direction
to go
in the service of solving cognitive
perceptual and affective problems and
more generally in the anticipation
and programming of actions and the
response to their outcomes
so simulation enhancement could be for
example um
i wake up and it's very dark in my room
but i have a generative model
um or an accessible model not um
being too formal here of my room so even
with
my eyes closed or with very dim light i
can
enhance my simulation and think oh wait
you know if i open the door this way
it's going to
wake up my roommate or if i do this at
this time
then down the road this is going to be a
different sensory input that i don't
want to experience
so that kind of rich mechanistic
understanding of the world
is what humans excel at and it's what
the current machines that we deal with
do not deal with
well um you can ask it a question like
could you know
this building wear ice skates and it
might be able to parse
whether those terms mean different
things and whether they're keywords used
by the same people or not on twitter
but will it be able to understand and
address that question
and that's kind of what the geb book
really is fun to think about
so again four functional features for
consciousness
should there be a fifth one are one of
these extraneous
do you have a different function for
consciousness what is your understanding
is consciousness have function
or is consciousness something else how
would it affect things if it had a
function
how would we measure the function what
is dysfunction
all these questions any questions that
people want to have
maybe be cool for people who watch it
like to post questions they have and we
can have
a norm of just asking the questions that
we have
out loud because let's ask the questions
i don't know any other way to say it
right now
the second thing that we'll talk about
is the
invariance of consciousness the
phenomenological invariance and
here i believe there are five so these
are the things
that are really what their model is
going to come down to with respect to
phenomenology and philosophy
so this is what they're going to focus
on this is what the mathematical model
needs to aim for
this is what their formalisms should
explain predict
integrate encompass um so this is like
the big core philosophy idea that we
want to do
all of the math and all of the
computational stuff to get at
with some type of bridge the bridge is
projective geometry
perhaps so what does it mean to be a
phenomenological invariant
and they write the following are the
deeply
interconnected invariants that we think
characterize consciousness
we take them as postulates for
mathematical treatment
citation that you could follow up on and
construct the pcm on their basis
so it's kind of like axioms like they're
taking these as like root statements
that kind of don't need to be justified
they're kind of like observations
but of course this is something that we
all want to know is
could there be another one could one of
these be redundant what if you have four
out of five do you get 80
on consciousness or what if we figure
out or imagine a system that has a
three out of five is it you know what
does that mean for that system
what are these phenomenological
invariants one
relational phenomenal intentionality
so break it down by the words all
consciousness involves the appearance of
a world
of objects properties etc in various
qualitative or representational worlds
representational ways to an organism so
again
they're not thinking too much about
worms and fruit flies and ants and ant
colonies maybe they are i'd love to hear
it from an author
or from a colleague if they are but um
these are the debates that we're having
which is like right if you observe the
worm moving away from the gradients
as if it had a representational
relational phenomenal
intentionality is that evidence enough
and that's the question two situated
three-dimensional spatiality of course
also there's time sometimes called the
fourth dimension
the space the presented world like
objects or etc
is three-dimensional again big asterisk
and perspectival unfolding in an
oriented manner between a point of view
and a horizon at infinity where all
parallel lines converge
the origin of this point of view is
elusive though normally it seems to be
located in the head
the space is normally organized around
the lived body so this is like
bringing us to embodiment to inactivism
to ecological psychology
to intercultural and developmental
psychology
to um ken wilbur's integral theory
also connecting us to lived experience
and to spatiality
and to the ways that the spaces that we
live in
influence who and how we are so all of
the awesome active stream participants
who have taught us so much about
embedded systems
and embodiment we'd really love to hear
what
is work in this area that impinges
on one of these invariants
multimodal synchronic integration
synchronic means at the same time
consciousness involves the synthesis or
integration into a unified whole of a
multiplicity of qualitative and
representational components from sensory
modalities memory and cognition so
diachronic
means at a different time synchronic at
the same time
so memory is diachronic but it's of
sensory modalities
so it could be a hearing event from six
months ago
um maybe you know and there's the whole
question of imagination obviously big
question but just to a first pass um
events from the past that influence us
in the future are diachronic or another
way to think about it is they modify the
system or they put it onto a different
trajectory
that's different than if that
difference-making cause to use the
waters terminology
hadn't occurred consciousness seems to
be both diacronic
and synchronic like when we're listening
to music and seeing flashing lights
there's like synchronization in the same
moment that's also multi-sensory
but there's some really interesting work
about the time durations of different
kinds of experience
so clearly something is happening there
with sight and sound
and just people who are born with or
without hearing and
born with or without sight all these
different people can navigate in the
same world
so that says something about sight you
know it's not just
us watching a projector if there's
people who can navigate without sight
so that's kind of what they want to
bring it back to four
temporal integration which i just hinted
at before but this is a little deeper
level
consciousness involves at least the
retention of immediately past
experiences
and pretension of immediately future
experiences as integral elements of its
species present the uh ever present now
as it were and the foundation for more
expansive forms of temporal integration
such as distant memories and long-term
planning
distant past distant future now just to
give one kind of funny note
when i was reading this i thought what
is protection what does it mean in this
context
so according to google protection is a
philosophy word
that means anticipation of a future
event
so i dug a little deeper into the
merriam-webster
definition of protent p-r-o-t-e-n-t
tent like a professionally set up tent
it's an archaic transitive verb meaning
to stretch
forth or to extend now
nowadays one might hear about portending
future events
not protecting them um and the words
actually have different meanings
so to pretend p o r t e n d
por tend is to um convey something
through like a symbol or an omen
like the the owl pretended difficult
times or something like that
but um portenting is something that the
agent does
in response to the symbol so um upon
seeing the owl
you know the farmer decide portented
that this was going to occur
and so i would just kind of bring up
this idea that maybe they're so similar
sounding and they're so kind of close in
their word usage
that the english language just couldn't
tolerate
um that much ambiguity because
portenting and portending they sound
like 99 identical
and so then maybe portending took
popularity over protent
because it removes agency from the actor
and so it's one way to remove action
from language
and so now protecting or portenting
it's now a philosophy word it's archaic
it's an old word
because we can't have action in speech
right no but
non-ironically it is really interesting
to think about how these words change in
meaning and
the more action we can embed in our
speech patterns and our interaction
patterns the better
subjective character so subjective
character is defined by the authors
as involving a pre-reflective
non-conceptual awareness
of oneself and their individuality now
one could be totally off base
so they can be wrong is that part of
consciousness to be wrong about your
individuality or is it just that you're
having an individuality
hard to say but the authors have it as
an invariant
they write also that two to five are
in fact implicated in one so relational
phenomenal intentionality is really the
most important key invariant so that's
the relational thinking and that's why
i feel like the active inference and
free energy principle communities
are very adjacent to complexity thinking
to systems thinking
relational thinking design thinking as
well as
team collaboration frameworks because so
many of these
social work and team relation frameworks
as well as other types of thinking
including complexity
they all deal with this relational
insight so there's so much to learn
and to do here and to understand about
what are the implications of relational
thinking on consciousness
on our own experience if not on actually
making claims about consciousness
cool let's just kind of close out by
going through and looking briefly at a
few of the figures and just
what they're about take a 30 000 foot
view so that when you're reading through
the paper
you kind of know where you're coming
from so figure one
has um a b or and c and um
a is a projective solution to a
vr mediated disassociation in phenomenal
selfhood
so this is kind of like um from the
experience of uh the euclidean
view like that we're looking at
minecraft here
and then the person their head is in
this like block
in the lived space in the right side of
figure a
and um but they're imagining the space
as if it were on the left side of a
so i can imagine my office right now in
terms of the right angles again
even when i look out i don't see right
angles if i were to
combine like this and i look back down
and look at the angle that the room was
just making
it's a 90 degree angle but it looks
normal within my generative
and usually verified experience that it
is 90 degrees
because why projective geometry so
what do we have to do well it turns out
to add in this element of the visual
field in the projective geometry
in b we're going to show this like sort
of
they call it an anti-space beyond the
plane i'm not even gonna
go into what that may or may not be
because i don't want to um
go down too deep but it's kind of like
there's some mapping
reflected in b and c what they call
god's eye vantage point
there's certain mappings from b and c
just like there's a mapping
between the understanding that i'm in a
euclidean office
and then my lived experience where
apparently wherever my eyes are
or something like that right a little
bit behind there a little in front of
there
um how are we going to square the circle
almost literally with the generative
model of the euclidean office
with my lived experience of the wacky
angles
and what's interesting here is the
visual focus
and so where are all of these different
centers is this kind of related to like
what if we feel like our emotional
center is somewhere
else in our body or what if we um have
the experience
of not just a simple outer body like
floating above your body looking down
but more expansive experiences so we'd
love to go into that phenomenology with
someone potentially from alias or any
other colleague
um and so there's certain mappings just
like euclidean to non-euclidean office
there's this like
god's eye mapping you can evaluate for
yourself whether you think that's god's
eye
figure two is a projective solution to
the neck or cube
and so here's what's happening in this
image on the left side
is like two versions of the so-called
necker cube illusion so it's a cube
visual illusion and it turns out it's
illusion
first off just looking at these two for
one or for both just ask yourself
do i see them as um
[Music]
how should i even say this the biggest
side
that's close to you is it on the top
left
of each square or is it on the bottom
right
and you can flip sometimes some people
different people in different ways
can flip in their mind seeing it as if
the biggest side of the box
were coming down to the right or
whether the biggest part of the box is
kind of going up into the left
okay now here is why they
are suggesting that this um visual
illusion exists because there's no
perspectival cues
we're looking into a projection on a
flat plane
and so there's sort of like two optimal
solutions
to the perspectival question and so
because there's two
such similar um evidence competing
models
free energy minimizing models it's b
it's not
they say it's undecidable free
energy-based inference which is to say
that in our optimization perception we
continue just oscillating it's like
you know it's the old woman it's the
young woman
it's the old woman it's the young woman
okay that's a visual illusion
but this is one that has to do with
projective geometry
where it's like it's coming towards me
like but i'm getting sensory evidence
that's going that way
in a different simulated frame and then
you perceive it that way now it's top
down so it's like this um
back and forth resonance and there's a
lot of interesting research on this
what breaks the symmetry quite literally
and the answer is
lived experience from the point of view
simulation so here
if i'm closer to one side of the square
i don't have any little squares to pick
up
but it resolves it not absolutely you
still know that square has a different
side or the cube has a different side
and you can even imagine what it might
look like like oh i'm seeing the six
is the on the die it's closest to me if
i were on the other side i would see a
one
and it would look bigger and i wouldn't
be able to see the six
but where i'm at i just see a big
rectangle six or something like that
and so that kind of captures a lot of
these aspects of the geometry of
consciousness
where you can simulate being in
different places but you're always
in a certain spot visualizing it what is
that spot that's the privilege point of
view that's the point of reference
what about it is special well it's like
a non-arbitrary point
in a projective geometry what kind of
projective geometry
well something that takes our allegedly
euclidean world
and maps it into this like vanishing
point
experience i think i got some of the
main
uh threads to link there but that's kind
of what they're
suggesting and free energy is going to
be the optimization
and action and inference paradigm within
a simulation broadly construed
understanding
about how symmetry is broken
in terms of experience so big stuff
interesting topics you know to be
wanting to address this is
big by the authors
figure 3 is a pcn based simulation of a
pit challenge and on the very bottom
you'll see this is like from another
paper
so if you're curious about this
simulation definitely go
check out the other paper that they
reference but
what we can look at here is um starting
on the left side
so there's like a bunch of barbell
shapes
and basically the barbell uh has to do
with it's like a map they can walk
around in so they can wander around but
they kind of have to make it across
this pit to get to like a rewarding
place
so there's an anhedonic uh in a safe
space a challenge room and a goal room i
believe is what they call them
and then they're going to be thinking
about that that
moving circle like let's see if i can do
this there you go this moving circle
is like the agent moving through the map
here's
its expectations and where its prior
beliefs are and then here is it
resolving its uncertainty in a it's kind
of like looks like a radar dial
but that white spot in the middle is
like the
the non-arbitrary origin that's like the
consciousness zone and so from the pov
point of view of this organism
in its foc it's field of consciousness
which is like some geometry mapping
from the um experienced space
into its generative model it's
navigating that mapping
somehow through consciousness and then
that's also able to bear
on the difference between like having a
weaker imagination
and a stronger imagination they have
this active inference
engine with um multi-sensory integration
and
this looks like something definitely to
go into for the
9.1 and for our own future uh research
but basically we can
run model scenarios we can say yeah i
guess if it
it's a funny thing to say you know i can
imagine that if you were to do this
experiment
you might find informative results
suggesting that enabling an
agent to have imagination in an
action-oriented geometry might enable it
to do better than a model that doesn't
therefore
spending most of its time learning about
relationships that may or may not be
relevant
in the geometrical frame that sensory
data actually occur
in again long sentences abound but
i think that um there's a lot there in
figure three
and also a lot to learn about how
they're framing free energy
all right last figure figure four
figure four is an overall sketch of the
pcm the projective consciousness model
and i think there's a few different
dimensions here
so one is the observer at the center
with their lived space uh steven this
really reminds me of the parry personal
space so i hope that you'll have a lot
to teach us
in this domain and within this domain
this field of consciousness
field of affordances let's think about
it from many different perspectives
just by saying one thing i'm not always
meaning to limit i'm just saying that
this is one way we can think about it
let's imagine
that there are perceived and imagined
events
now observations are just models of
observations so maybe there's less of a
distinction there than might be seen
but in this geometry
observer centric with all of this
projective geometry mapping happening
can we think about aligning your vector
through time down a gradient
that goes from red to green so it's
funny because it's a gradient that
colorblind people of certain types may
not be able to perceive
which just so perfectly entails
everything we're talking about here
which is that um action in some like
absolutist
sense is moving downhill
thermodynamically there's very few
people who would say that action moves
uphill
thermodynamically bring them on the
stream but
it has to go uphill conceptually or
symbolically in certain cases
if not just simply logistically in terms
of going uphill to go downhill later
and so here we see a gradient reflecting
the free energy
going um from a culturally based
green is okay and low surprise
and then red is high surprise high alert
high attention
where have we seen that before um taking
that kind of a culturally imbued color
scale
and then aligning a time vector as a
dimensional projection
onto that figure as a way to say that
actually
through space and time in the context of
the projected geometry and affordance
capacities of the organism
it is still downhill in a sense so
i don't know where this um necessarily
fits in
with uh all the mathematical formalisms
here looks pretty nice to talk about
like the action perception
prediction imagination loop this is
another loop we might want to learn
about we've talked a lot about loops
related to like agent and environment
but now we're almost thinking like
the agent within the agent is going from
action perception prediction imagination
so that's something happening inside of
us potentially and then again on the
right side is looking
at time series that's the directions we
want to take all free energy research is
like
through time through space any other
dimensions we come across
we'll go through those two but that's
definitely the cool
dimension to think about is deep causal
inference
with the sound and what's visualized in
the figure
so other people may see very different
things in this
figure and we welcome hearing about it
let's close with some just um final
thoughts and questions to end on which
maybe we'll start ending with questions
more they write in their paper
computationalist a posteriori that means
after the fact
identity theory allows that apparently
contingent processing constraints
may be essential to real consciousness
as long as the computational model
captures the phenomenological invariance
meets the functional constraints and
survives the tribunal
of prediction and experiment we should
happily accept that some
apparently contingent and only
empirically knowable constraints
pertaining to the physical realization
of consciousness are actually essential
to it
so that is basically like saying look if
we do
the if we can explain and predict the
invariance the five invariants
and we can capture these functional
attributes there's four of them
but again both of those sets the
invariances and the functional
attributes
anyone is game to add remove or change
it just needs to be justified and
understood so they're saying look if it
does both of those things which is why
i spent so much time on it in this talk
was because
that's their claim it's not just broadly
we could do active inference and think
about consciousness
it's saying if we make these invariances
part of our model
and we at least get all the functional
attributes that we want
then any model that is surviving
unique explanation and predictions the
tribunal
the uh the troika as it were if it does
all of that
then it is basically going to come along
with some wacky baggage like a parameter
we don't understand
or the god's eye view and then they're
just saying you're just gonna have to
accept that as contingent
so fun thought by the authors just
a really well written and conveyed paper
and i hope that it broaches onto many
areas that we've
talked about in other active streams
here's my closing set of questions
one how would we recognize a framework
for consciousness
and a related question is what might a
framework for consciousness be
what if it's a poem oh well it can't be
a poem how do we know
or what if it's a drawing or what if
it's a set
of ontologies narratives formal
documents and tools
could it be that onft could it be bolts
business operational legal technical
social
um could it be acceptance could it be
fundamental agnosticism um could it be
free energy principle
how will we know and that is really the
key
question for theories of consciousness
is not
do you feel right it's how will we know
and do you hold yourself to that
standard because we can do a lot better
in this area and this paper is an
example of great work in the space
a next question is what might a
framework for consciousness enable
and that's pretty broad what would it
change in our action
practice would we put more people in
fmri scanners or less
would we communicate with people who we
don't think of as being able to
communicate with at this point
or not why not um how might it change
our legal systems or
our social systems what if we could
measure
different kinds or types or levels of
consciousness
and then that's really why we need to
get down to the brass tacks on what it
might look like what it measures
and what the predictions are because if
we don't know the unique predictions or
experiments
and this is alluding to earlier when i
said that there's a lot on the table
someone's going to say well i have a
consciousness ometer and
this is a 2 and this is an 11 and this
type of object that you care so much
about is actually it's not conscious so
i'm just going to unplug it
but this other one that i care a lot
about i measured it with my device and
it was very
conscious it's very worthwhile to save
and
where will people make a stand and the
stand has to be
on the common ground and the space of
recognition
of frameworks for consciousness in my
opinion i'm open to changing my mind on
that
but i think if we don't meet at how
we'll recognize such a framework what it
might look like
and start with respecting world
knowledge traditions and by respecting
differences in our opinion
and we stay in a hegemonic mode in a um
absolutist mode in a um non-pluralist
frame culturally methodologically if we
don't go
down um the pluralistic route it's gonna
be
i think very bad for practical
implications
and then lastly um what are the next
steps for active inference
in this domain what do we want an active
inference conscious
agent to do or how can we build on
active inference
now do we want to go deeper into
consciousness
deeper into action we spoke about action
policy selection and machine learning
could we put consciousness machine
learning what would be the philosophy
and the implications of that these are
all big questions
but how are we going to take this paper
and develop in the directions of active
inference
even if only making um educational
content
and then lastly um maybe always a good
question to address
is what is the goal of this research
sure we're curious about consciousness
but aren't we curious about so many
things
what makes it worthwhile to do this
research
why are we doing it how have we selected
or how why have we selected or how how
have we selected our why
every one of these combinations we
really need to keep in mind
especially if it's about us about our
experience about consciousness about
people
it's just again can't be said enough
that there's too much on the table
to not have this be participatory
inclusive
cross-cutting intercultural the list
just
goes on so everybody who's listening and
thinking about
it thanks so much this kind of uh i
guess went a little bit longer than
one might have predicted but c'est la
vie right when active streaming why not
thanks for participating we will provide
follow-up forms to the
live participants we actually will
believe it or not
we will request your feedback
suggestions
and questions so if you have any
thoughts again i tried to drop a bunch
of times really specific
moments where somebody could just pause
the video and say
yes this thing right here i do or don't
agree with or this does or doesn't
resonate with my experience
that would be epic because let's hear
from a lot of perspectives on
consciousness it's important to hear
about that
and then also just any feedbacks or
suggestions or collaboration offers for
the act
imp stream always welcome you can stay
in communication with us
any of our channels or means but
thank you all for listening those of you
who are listening live or those of you
who will listen in replay
because the future is always now isn't
it
see you later